delicious out porn soup now this is
perfect winter's evening and it's so
easy to do at the end of it is so
delicious right first things first
chilies ginger and lemongrass okay okay
now the idea now is just cutting them up
roughly don't worry about sort of fine
dicing it because we actually pass and
strain the soup at the end well done for
now ginger lemongrass what's right okay
okay and then Wally's are sharp nice
watch your fingers right nice things are
great by the way thanks French it's just
cut on the top yeah all the way through
yes okay and then from there no need to
chop them finely because it will sit
this out oh great doc oh boy have you
done your lemongrass as well oh yes no
wanna just cut and just slice that down
about that that's it beautiful ginger on
it
sorry now it's all in from there great
so you should sugar it right yes it good
well then now that starts the sort of
sweet in the broth okay makes it a lot
more sort of authentic from there a
little bit of fish sauce yeah four
tablespoons where's that fish sauce
right all in front there your
tablespoons right one two three and four
roller because you get more juice there
you go good boy yeah right cut that in
half okay and then these all that line
into your stock okay well done well done
now a little touch of black pepper we
don't need any salt because of the fish
sauce okay just a few turns of black
pepper now where do you seriously learn
to cook hm Jamie Oliver really
he's he's he's missing
yeah but when I was when I was growing
up he is the first person that kind of
made cooking call on techno and I would
watch the show but I would think wow
great you know and so he I feel that he
started I feel like he he got me erect
and you're about to finish me a good
roast and are quite like yeah you know
your beef wellington anyone's cook
Gordon's befriends it is the best recipe
easy delicious para ham the mushrooms
lush pastry mushrooms talk about
mushrooms now huge perfect timing
yes the mushrooms okay three or four
don't worry about get them home
okay now the exciting thing about these
mushrooms okay there should taki
mushrooms they cook so easily
yeah now right Jeff and Barry how are
you mushrooms getting on yep now
seriously tell me is Barry as bad as it
looks and governor Stacy hey come on now
Gordon the Beautiful playing on a blue
book available he's right I usually what
he's saying this that's right don't go
in I got so loading this could fish
shops
I've got miss them
look at that